Our next speaker is one of our
keynote speakers for the day.
And he is Brian Nosek.
Brian is Co-founder
and Executive Director
of the Center for Open Science,
which operates the Open Science
Framework.
The Center for Open Science
is a nonprofit technology
organization based in
Charlottesville, Virginia
with a mission to increase
the openness, integrity,
and reproducibility of
scientific research.
Brian is a professor in the
Department of Psychology
at the University of Virginia.
He received his
undergraduate degree
from California Polytechnic
State University and a PhD
from Yale University.
Welcome home.
He co-founded Project
Implicit, an internet-based
multi-university collaboration
between researchers
and education investigating
implicit cognition.
Important topic today.
Professor Nosek
investigates the gap
between values and practices,
such as when behavior
is influenced by factors
other than one's intentions
and goals.
Research applications
of this interest
are implicit bias, decision
making, attitudes, ideology,
morality, and
barriers to change.
He applies the
scientific research
to improve the alignment between
personal and organizational
values and practices.
In 2015 Professor
Nosek was named
as one of Nature
magazine's Nature's 10.
And in the same year, The
Chronicle of Higher Education
added him to its Influence List.
Welcome, Professor Brian Nosek.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks very much.
You want to get me started here?
I very much appreciate the
invitation for this event
and hope that what
I talk about is
seen as very relevant
to the things
that the institution and the
university is working on.
I'm Nosek there.
Thank you.
So the Center for Open
Science was founded in 2013.
It is a nonprofit
technology company,
as Jill mentioned,
with a mission
to increase openness,
integrity, and reproducibility
of research.
And we have four primary
activities-- thank you--
for that.
One is meta science,
where we are conducting
large-scale studies
of the reproducibility
of different fields, or research
on just scientific practices
itself to identify areas
to improve reproducibility.
A second is that we
conduct trainings
about how to be more
reproducible or open in one's
research, what
tools are available,
and how to use them effectively.
A third area that gets
a lot of our attention
is working on the
incentives in scholarship
to try to align
what's good for me
as a scientist with
what's good for science.
So can we make it
in one's interest
to be more open and
reproducible in their work,
make that part of
the reward structure
rather than having it just
focused on publication
as frequently as possible in
the most prestigious outlets
possible?
That was the focus of my
presentation yesterday.
What I want to focus on today
is the last thing that we do,
which is most of the staff.
We have about 75 people now at
the center, and most of them
are working on
infrastructure, building tools
to help open and enable greater
integration and reproducibility
of the entire research
lifecycle as public goods
infrastructure for
the community to use.
So let me open with sort of
what the organizing principle
of our strategy for
research infrastructure.
And that is that academic
scholarship, when
done for academic
purposes, is a public good,
that what the pursuit
of knowledge is
is not for my
knowledge unless I'm
pursuing competitive advantage
or commercialization.
But when I'm pursuing it
for academic purposes,
I'm pursuing it for
the good of humanity
to know new things that I have
contributed as a researcher.
So if we think of the role of
scholarship as a public good,
a concrete application
of that is,
what does it mean to have
that be a public good?
And there are three areas
that we pay most attention to
in openness.
One is open access of the
outcomes-- the publications
that result, the scholarship
that comes out of what it is I
found in my process
of discovery,
of my generation of data and
interpretation of that data.
Second is the theme of
the day, the open data,
the content of research, and
not just the data in terms
of the units that were
generated from the methodology,
but information about
the methodology itself,
the materials that were done,
the process that was done,
the code that was generated.
All of that is the
content of what's
actually in the research.
As David Donahoe
at Stanford said,
the publication is really
advertising for the research.
The research itself is down
here, the content of what
was generated that led
to that publication.
And the third area
we think is vital,
and not as much part of
the conversation yet,
but really is the critical part
of representing that research
lifecycle, which is the
workflow, the process
of generating that data,
of drawing inference,
of coming up with designs.
How is it that I conducted
that research in order
to arrive at those outcomes?
And that has just as much
a role to play as the data
itself that was generated.
And so that really is a key
part of our overall strategy
of trying to open up the
entire research lifecycle.
So let me just drill down
a bit into the benefits
that we perceive of open
workflows to then transition
into our technology strategy.
One is obvious.
It's in the name.
It increases process
transparency.
How is it that I
arrived at my research?
If you can see my
workflow, if you
can see the history
of my work, then you
have information about
that and can evaluate it.
It increases my accountability
to how it is I draw inference.
If I do 500 different tests
on a particular data set
and only share five of them
with you, the ones that
looked really good, if you can
see my process of doing that,
then you can decide whether that
was a reasonable thing to do
or not.
If you don't see my process,
then you don't know,
and I have no accountability
to other observers
to how it is I
generated my findings.
Open workflows also
facilitate reproducibility
in that if you see how it
is I conducted the research,
you have much more
information to be able to do
that same thing yourself.
Also, it facilitates
metascience.
If you want to study
how it is people draw
scientific inferences, or
scholarly inferences more
generally, you
need to have access
to how it is that those
inferences are generated.
And so conducting research
on the research process
itself requires access
to the data about how
the research was conducted.
Moreover, it fosters
collaboration
in that as those
workflows are open,
there are more opportunities
for people with expertise
at different stages
of the life cycle
to get involved in
that research process.
Researchers in laboratories
around our university--
perhaps here as well--
don't think a lot about curation
of their data in advance.
But those are skills that
are available on university
campuses.
Librarians have lots
of duration skills
that, if they could get
inserted earlier in the research
process, could help
set up data so that it
is more accessible, more
reusable, and better
curated for future use.
Also, open workflows
foster inclusivity
by giving more touch
points for people
with different areas of
expertise and interest
to get involved in the
research lifecycle, wherever it
is they could be contributors.
Moreover, that
fosters innovation,
because as you can see
more of the lifecycle,
there are more opportunities
to identify friction points
or gaps that could be addressed
with different types of tools.
And most critically
for our purposes
is that an open workflow
protects against lock-in.
So an easy strategy to build
commercial business on research
is to get researchers
in at one point
and keep them in the types
of tools that one develops.
Apple has a fantastic strategy
to keep me using Apple products
by connecting all those
things together so that I'm
dependent on them.
And I thank them
for it, and I keep
buying more things from them.
So it is a great strategy
for commercialization,
but it isn't a great strategy
for research advancement
for public goods
because if I am locked
in a particular set of
tools and services, then
I don't have
opportunity to innovate.
opportunity to bring
in other services that might
be most relevant to what
it is I need to do.
And it's then contingent on a
particular provider rather than
all of the potential service
providers of a research
ecosystem.
So that sort of is the baseline
core of what the Open Science
Framework aims to do.
And really, the
representation, the process
that we are trying to have an
impact on in reproducibility
is that entire
research lifecycle,
from the generation of ideas
to the collection of that data
to how it is stored and
analyzed, how it is then
represented and interpreted.
And so all of the tools
are reinforcing that.
So I want to give
a quick impression
of what the overall strategy
is and then unpack it
piece by piece.
We essentially are pursuing
three layers of infrastructure
to help support opening up
the entire research lifecycle.
A base level infrastructure
of the tools and services
that developers create
and maintain that
then facilitate the
creation of interfaces,
ways in which researchers
then engage with those tools
and services in order to
conduct their research
at different parts
of the lifecycle.
And then those interfaces
enable branding and engagement
of communities by them
taking those services
and having it represented
for their own community
with their own norms,
with their own standards,
with their own
rules of how it is
their community engages in that
type or that area of research.
And so what I'll do for
the rest of the talk,
essentially, is
unpack each of these
and show how it is
they fit together,
starting at the bottom, so the
core set of tools and services
that the team is developing.
So the first one
is the tool kit.
So most of the team, over
the last three and 1/2
years that we've
been working, has
been developing a
suite of open services
that are composable,
that represent workflow,
authentication, how one
gets access to a system,
permissions, what
different users have access
to, file storage
tools, file rendering
in a browser, persistence
and a meta-database,
integrations connecting
services together,
search and discovery
functionality,
and the shared data set.
These are composable
tools so that anyone that
is trying to build a new service
that operates via the internet
can draw on any of
these pieces in order
to lower the barrier to
entry, make it easier and more
efficient for them to create a
new service, a new interface,
a new way to engage researchers,
but on a common framework
of tools so that it is much
more efficient and much more
interoperable across the
different tools and services
that researchers create.
There's a whole lot that we
could talk about with that,
but I just want to
give you impression
of what the toolkit is.
And you want all of it,
it's all right there.
So that is critical
because this is
the basis of all of the things
that get built on top of it.
And one of the key pieces
is the services ecosystem.
What the services
ecosystem is is it's
based on an abstracted API
at the core of these tools
and services.
And the entire idea
of this approach
is to have any service that is
connected to the Open Science
Framework is then connected
to all of the other services
around the research lifecycle.
So for example, right now we
have connections with Mendeley
and Zotero as citation
management tools,
some data collection
tools like Open Sesame,
data storage environments like
Google Drive or Amazon Web
Services, Dropbox, GitHub,
statistical analytics,
tools like JASP Stats-- it's
an open source analytics tool--
and then places where
people archive their data
like FigShare and Dataverse
So as each service adds their
connection to the Open Science
Framework, then
they can speak with,
interact with all of the other
services in that ecosystem.
And once that happens,
then lock-in is prevented.
If I have my data in Dataverse
and then suddenly Dataverse
goes commercial and
bananas and they
start to do things
that I don't like,
I can move my
content out of that
instantly into another service.
And I can add additional
services to my workflow
by just connecting
different tools that I use.
So those are the ones that
are already completed.
We gave out grants to a
variety of different groups
to add additional services to
just demonstrate connections
across the entire
research lifecycle,
so that, for example,
you can imagine someone
doing their data management
planning with DMP tool.
And instead of that
being a static document
that, once I get the
grant, I never look
at again, because why
would I look at it again?
I got the grant.
I'm just doing my research now.
Instead, that can become
a living document that
travels along the
research lifecycle,
and as the relevant
items in the data plan
become relevant in
the research process,
then we might be able to
facilitate and connect
that with the
movement of that data
into data storage
devices, et cetera.
So just to give one
illustration of this,
Notre Dame has a computational
services environment
for their researchers,
and they were
building an interface
to try to connect that
to different data storage
environments, box.com, Dropbox,
et cetera.
They discovered that we started
to collaborate and identify
areas of common
interest, and instead
of continuing on developing
their own interface,
they connected their
computational services platform
to the OSF.
And then because it's
connected to this API,
now instantly their
computational services
is connected to all of
the data stores that
are connected to the OSF.
So they could say, call from
this data storage environment,
send it to our
computational platform,
and then output the results
to the Open Science Framework.
This has a dramatic
effect on efficiency
because every time someone
else adds their data storage
environment to the OSF,
then that's instantly
part of their computational
services platform.
And they only have to maintain
one relationship with the Open
Science Framework.
They don't have to worry
about all of the connections
with all the other
services, which
are continually
getting updated and is
a substantial technical burden.
So the efficiency gains
for each organization,
each group involved, having
a single point of contact
can dramatically accelerate
the connection of services
more broadly.
We can talk about that more
if there are questions later,
but I want to move on to
some of the other pieces,
because that's really at the
core of a lot of what we do.
The next one is
data, and I'll just
talk first about metadata
of scholarly events.
And this is primarily through
a project called Share,
and this is a collaboration
with the Association
of Research Libraries.
And the idea of
Share is to identify
all of the different
providers of scholarly events.
So that might be a publication,
it might be a grant award,
might be a clinical
trial registration,
it might be an individual
researcher doing something,
it might be a data set being
made available in a repository.
There are lots of
different services
that have these
events occur and have
some kind of alert or
access point of metadata
about what that event is.
But they're all in
their own formats.
They all have different
metadata styles.
And so what Share
does is it takes
all of those different
services and normalizes them
into a single
format so that there
can be one pipeline of all
research events of any kind
where you can search against
that particular for anything
from any source.
Once we have that
pipeline, then we
are building curation
tools on top of it.
And so part of the key
with collaboration with ARL
is that there are
curation associates that
will connect these
different research events,
so that that data
set, oh, that's
related to that publication,
oh, and that grant award.
And if we can just connect them
together as related events,
then it's a lot
easier to discover.
For example, if
institutions want
to know what their
researchers are doing,
then a curated data set
can allow the development
of discovery layers
on top of that
that are focused on research
events by their faculty.
So there are many different
uses for an open dataset
of all research
events because you
can develop lots of
different discovery layers
on top of that.
So where we are
so far with Share
is that there are 16
million events, as of a day
or two ago when I
screenshot this,
and from 126 different sources.
That's institutional
repositories
with groups like CrossRef
or Datasite or FigShare.
And they are all searchable
through a single interface.
And that shared dataset, now,
because its an open data set,
can be applied to any new
service that anybody builds.
They can use the shared data
set as their search engine,
and that's what we use for all
the services that we develop.
So that's sort of the core
layer of tools and services
that other things that
researchers need to use
can be built upon.
So I want to talk next about
the second layer, which
is the interfaces that
we're developing as example
cases for what
researchers can build,
or what scholarly
communities can
build to interact with the types
of scholarship that they do.
Our best-known
interface, and the one
we've worked on the
most, is at osf.io.
It's also termed the
Open Science Framework,
but really it is
an interface, too,
that is separate from those
core tools and services.
And so what OSF does
for researchers is it's
a project management
environment.
And it tries to draw on
all of those services
into a very flexible integrated
system that helps researchers
maintain their own research for
their own purposes privately,
but make it very
easy to make parts
of that publicly accessible.
So for example, you sign up for
an account as an individual.
When you have an
account, you go in
and you have a project space.
You can create projects.
You add collaborators
to those projects.
You can drop data and
materials, anything digital,
into those projects.
You organize them,
and you have things
like Wikis and other
management things
just to maintain that
project internally
for your team's own use, a
cloud-based archiving access
point so that distributed
teams, collaborative teams all
know where to find the stuff.
And it will never get lost, even
if the graduate student leaves
or the computer explodes.
So it sort of looks like that.
A second feature of it is it
has a simplified version control
interface.
Some researchers understand
and can use things like Git
to engage version control
with the work that they do,
but that's not something
that many researchers use,
even though they can appreciate
the value of version control.
Most of what version control
happens in-- for example,
authoring--
is creating a single
folder on one's desktop
and saying, Manuscript
Final and then
Manuscript Final
Final, Manuscript,
this is the final one.
Don't look at the other ones.
And so there's a
continuing array
of these versioned
articles of what
it was that was being written.
But it's very hard to
keep track of that.
This does it automatically so
that every time the file gets
updated, then it
creates a new version,
but you have access
to the entire version
history of that file,
whatever's in the file.
So it makes it much easier,
lowers the barrier to entry
to use things like version
control for researchers,
regardless of their
technology tendencies.
A key part of the
OSF is that it merges
public and private workflows.
One of the big
barriers to getting
into being more open with
one's data and research
is that most of the practices
now require me to add on,
append new work to the work
that I've already done.
So once I get my
publication, the journal
says, now would be great
if you opened your data.
And I think, what are
you talking about?
I'm done.
I've got my publication.
You want to do more things now?
I'm busy.
I've got to go onto
the next publication.
If instead we can integrate
the preparation for open data
with the workflow as
it happens, then we
don't have to append
onto the process
making one's data available.
Instead, we can
have an environment
that I'm using for
private purposes,
but all of the components have
a little button up at the top
that says Make Public.
And if I click the
button, it says,
are you really sure you
want to make this public?
And if I say yes, then that
part of the project is public.
And so I can continue to work
on my project while making
different parts of it-- whatever
parts I'm prepared to or can
make available--
make it publicly accessible.
And so that private
workflow for lab management
is simultaneously integrated
with a public workflow,
and there's no extra work to
make things publicly available.
It also integrates things
like incentives for openness.
Why is it that I
want to be open?
Well, the things that
I can appeal to myself
for wanting to be open
is seeing how many
people download
the work that I do,
having the opportunity for
people to fork my project
and make use of it themselves.
Forking is a concept imported
from open source software
development that is a
functional citation.
You did something that
I can adapt and use,
so I will fork
what you have done.
I will make some
adaptation of it
for some new use,
some new design
of this particular study,
some new methodology that's
inspired by yours or
developed on top of yours.
But there's always a functional
link back to the origin.
And so as different
methodologies
or different
datasets evolve over
time with many
different contributors,
you can trace the history
through the network
of how it is that work was
done to see an originator's
influence on the
development trajectory
or particular type of
research or phenomenon.
It also has persistence
citable identifiers
that link to the content
of the identifier
rather than just being a link
to where content might persist.
So every piece of every
component, every project,
every comment, everything
that's done on the Open Science
Framework has a
unique identifier
to preserve that content.
And citations are
automatically generated
to facilitate the idea that
making more of one's research
process available-- not just
the publication, but also
the dataset, materials,
and otherwise-- those
are scholarly objects
themselves that
are deserving of
citation and credit
as contributions, just
as the publication is.
Also, you can add DOIs
and other, more standard
persistent identifiers.
So I'll do two more
features and then move on
to the other parts.
And one is registration.
So there are different points
in the research lifecycle
that are important that
I want to call out,
as this is a point in time
that is worth paying attention
to and preserving.
So with the Open
Science Framework,
if I am, for example,
at the point of getting
ready to start data
collection, and I want to say,
this was the state
of the project
as data collection commenced.
Here's the design,
here's our analysis plan,
here's all the things that
we think we're going to do,
data collection
is about to start.
I can register the project,
sort of provide some metadata
about what the project is
for, why we're doing it,
what the plan is,
and then it creates
a permanent archived version
of the state of the project
at that point in time.
So I can continue to work on
the project and change things,
but I have a registered
version that's archived and put
into our long
preservations store
so that none of that
information for that time
will ever be lost.
And it's date and time
stamped, as registries do,
to sort of provide some
independent assurance
of when and what was happening.
Last is drawing on that
services ecosystem.
It connects all those
services together,
but it provides an
interface so that if I
am using GitHub for my
code, Amazon simple storage
for some large files, and
Dropbox for my everyday files,
I can connect all
of those together
into a single
interface and just drag
and drop and interact
between them,
rather than having to jump
to lots of different services
and potentially lose information
or memory about where things
are and how to access things if
different users are using each
of those different services.
So that's osf.io, but that's
just one interface that
can be built on that
core set of services.
We also have a variety
of other services
that we are building as
examples of interfaces that
can be built. But because
this is all open source,
the community can decide, I have
an interface, I have an idea,
I have a different way in which
I would draw on those services
to represent the scholarship
or the research process
that is of interest to me.
So I want to give just
a couple of examples.
One, OSF Institutions.
So we have an
institutional view where,
if the institution wants better
discovery of research that's
happening by scholars
at their institutions,
if they want to facilitate
researchers' ease of getting
into the system, then we
connect with single sign
on, if they have an
oauth type of connection,
so that researchers can log
in with their own university
accounts.
And we have a face page
for those universities
to be able to
track what research
is being done and made available
on the Open Science Framework.
So that is, like all of our
services, a free service.
And so we have a
variety of institutions
that have signed up
for that and have now
their own interfaces for
engaging with the Open Science
Framework and
facilitating researchers'
engagement with the service.
But that sort of leads
to the top layer, which
is the community services
aspect of this, which
is putting these services in
the hands of the communities
themselves to have
their own governance
and standards for how it is
they work with these services.
So I want to give an example
of that with OSF pre-prints.
So we launched this
service earlier this fall,
which is an open pre-print
repository network,
and that's the address.
But it draws on a few key pieces
of those underlying layers.
The first is that the search
in the pre-print service
is not search of just
pre-prints on OSF,
but search of pre-prints
across any pre-print provider.
So here are the ones that are
connected so far, so that it's
an aggregator of pre-prints
wherever those pre-prints are
stored.
And so this draws
on the Share service
that connects all
of these services
together into a single format.
And so search goes on Archive,
Bio Archive, Cogprints,
[INAUDIBLE] Archive,
PeerJ Sci Archive, RePEc,
Soc Archive, for now.
And then as more things
get added to Share, then
they're also represented
in that search.
It also has a very
simple workflow
for adding one's own pre-prints
so that you can post pre-prints
very easily to
accelerate communication.
The OSF version of it is for
any discipline, is agnostic just
to facilitate sharing of
pre-prints wherever you are.
But the key part is
that that interface can
be branded for any community.
So we have open invite for
partnerships of different
groups that want to start
to promote pre-prints
in their particular community,
whether it is disciplinary,
social sciences,
whether it is topical--
there is a group for open
optimism that is going to have
a pre-print service--
or whether it is institutional.
And so the Soc Archive
is one branded version
of that pre-print service.
This should release today,
is what I hear from the team.
Likewise today should come out
Engineering Archive and Psych
Archive for psychology.
So all of them have their
own steering committees,
their own standards
for what, content wise,
can be included
in their service.
And they have minimized
their infrastructure costs
because of the
shared infrastructure
that supports all of them.
So they don't have to
reinvent any of that.
They can focus on their
community and engagement
with their community.
So just to illustrate
what pre-print looks like,
so there's the pre-print as
it's shown in the browser.
It pulls on the file
rendering tools that
are part of that core service.
It draws on the OSF
projects themselves
and uses all of the contributor
tools that are there,
has links to DOIs if the article
is published so that you can
represent it there, and
then tags and things
for simplified discovery.
That model applies
to that overall model
that I described
at the beginning.
We have that core
set of tools that
enable the creation of a
pre-prints interface on top
of it that draws on those tools.
And then there are
branded interfaces,
community-based interfaces
using that sort of core
interface to make it
easier for communities
to engage their researchers,
their people in their community
on those services.
From our strategic perspective,
the reason to do these layers
is partly for
efficiency, but also
for allowing experts
to be experts.
As a psychologist,
I might think I
want to create a
pre-print service,
but in order to create
a pre-print service,
I have to build all these
tools that aren't really
my interests.
I'm interested in scholarly
communication in my community.
And so by layering these as
independent entities that
can be built on one another,
we can let technical experts
do the technical
work of how is it
that you deal with multiple
concurrent interactions moving
to scale for data
storage and transfer?
There's a lot of hard things
that, at scale, the technology
needs to be able to do,
and do very efficiently
and effectively.
And that's not something
that a psychologist-- me--
cares about.
That's something
that they care about,
and so let them be
expert at those tools.
Scholarly communication
experts care about how
is it that we are interacting?
How is it that we are
trying to get people
around this research lifecycle?
Let them have their
expertise in thinking
about those interfaces.
How is it that scholars should
engage with their research,
design those interfaces,
and then make those
interfaces available
to the content domain
experts to engage
their communities.
And so by segmenting them,
we get lots of efficiency
by cost, but also efficiency
by allowing experts
to focus on their areas
of expertise and interest
rather than saying,
oh, well, I have
to do these things in order
to get the thing that I want.
[INAUDIBLE] question
and answer part,
but I just want to make sure
you're clarifying on this.
So what you're basically doing
is saying [INAUDIBLE] platform
because you're feeding in
[INAUDIBLE] I want to create
a pre-print server in this area,
you're basically saying we can
help you get up and running in--
Tomorrow.
So you send the logo, you
send the phrase that you want.
So back up to this thing.
You send us this
logo and the name.
You send us this phrase.
You tell us-- it's not
shown below-- but you
tell us what are the
relevant disciplines for you.
And then we set it up,
and then you have it.
How many have done that so far?
So we have those three
will launch today,
I think, and there
are three more that
are signing the agreement for
us to offer those services.
And then there are
a number of others
that have expressed
interest, but they're
organizing their communities.
So we have that for pre-prints.
But you can instantly, now that
we have all of these tools,
you can imagine, at this
layer, generalizing that.
So the next thing that will
be coming out is registries.
Let's make it so
that anybody can
create a registry of what's
happening in their research
domain.
So it draws on these same tools.
It has very similar
interface as pre-prints,
but now it has particular
about that registration
process of documenting what
it is that the research is
going to be.
And we have partners
with egap and Ridie
already to move their
registries into this service.
And we have our own registries
that we already operate
that will be integrated there.
But same concept.
Dramatically low on the
barriers so that these groups
can focus on what is it
that's important to register
in developmental economics?
What do we have to say
about the research process
that we're doing in these RCTs?
And they answer those questions
of what's the content of it,
while these services worry
about how is it that it actually
gets executed and gets done?
So that-- how much
time do I have for--
seven minutes.
[LAUGHTER]
You don't want to open that
up because I really like that.
So let me talk just
in the last seven
minutes about sort
of the direction
that we're going with this.
So those services are intended
to provide more access, lower
the barrier to entry to
doing more open things.
The longer term strategy is
to address two challenges,
I think, to openness.
And that is rooted in the
idolization of publication
as the thing for advancement.
So one is to
separate publication
of scholarly content from
evaluation of that content.
Right now all of
my incentives are
get it published, because that's
the mechanism of reward for me.
And so for researchers,
if we can separate
the concept of publication
from evaluation,
then what we're
doing is separating
what is really the basis of
reputation management reward--
evaluation of the quality
of my research-- from what
is right now just
confounded with it
but not essential
for it, which is
the publication of that, the
sharing of that in the broader
community.
And pre-prints
already does that.
Pre-prints, essentially,
is publishing
before evaluation has occurred.
Second is that the publication
model, as it currently exists,
doesn't treat scholarly
content as a public good.
The basis of most monetization
strategies about publication
are on controlling
access to that content
rather than making
it openly accessible.
So you can imagine how this
community of pre-print services
can evolve.
So as more pre-print
services become available,
then they all develop different
standards, different norms
for what it is that's
content, the kind of content
that they host.
And as a consequence,
each of them
develop reputations, not
just for the content domain,
but for their quality standards,
for their evaluation standards
of what kinds of
research gets in.
And so what we're building
right now to enhance
these pre-print
services is a Comments
and Discussion pane so that
anybody in the community
interact about that
pre-print right
where the pre-print is, aligned
with post-publication peer
review.
If you consider the
pre-print made available,
now there can be peer review
discussion, perhaps peer review
discussion just
before you submit it
to a formal journal for
formal peer review process.
So that is active
development now,
and then we're also
in the planning stages
for building evaluation
of moderation
tools for pre-print services to
employ before they include it
in their service.
So Soc Archive, they'll
let any social science in.
I'm going to start a
social science pre-print
service that's really
focused on methodology
and have a high bar.
The methodology has to be
really solid before I let it
into our pre-print service.
And so I have an evaluation
system where we do peer review,
and we decide, is this worth
including in our service?
Once those two things are
done, then by and large,
this is publication.
It's the entire
publication system.
And if we add-- it's
too low here to see--
so I'll say some key
features of this,
in order to facilitate openness,
are that the authors retain
licensing.
So the author says
it's CC-BY or CC 0.
They're are not
passing the license
over to the pre-print service.
Articles are versioned--
remember version control--
so there's no finished article.
I can continue to revise
based on the feedback
that the community gives
about the quality of that work
rather than right now, the model
of once challenges or things
to improve in an
article identified,
if I'm motivated to do
it, I write a comment,
and that comment is published
as a separate thing, which
is never discovered
when people are
looking at the original thing.
And it opens up the
opportunity to diversify
evaluation heuristics.
So how is the information
about the quality of that work
communicated?
Right now the heuristic
that is most accessible
is the grade level
of the journal.
Is that an A journal, is
that an A minus journal,
is that a B journal?
And what I do in my
publication process
is I submit to them serially
until I get it into one.
It's an A. No, it's
not an A. A-minus.
No, it's not an A minus.
B plus.
No, it's not a B plus.
And so this is a huge waste
of time for everybody.
So you can imagine a
service that instead
of assigning a grade
level, it says,
we're going to assign the score.
Submit it to one service
and they say, you got a 75.
That's a C. And I
say, am I OK with a C?
At least I got that
information quickly.
It's a C. But I
think it's better,
and so I respond to the
reviews, I make changes,
and I resubmit it, thinking
that I can increase my grade.
And so you can have a much
more efficient process
of evaluation, which we use as
the heuristics for publication
more generally by allowing
diversification innovation
on how evaluation happens
in an open system.
The other implication
of authors licensing
is that it breaks the
one-to-one model of one article
is in one journal.
So if I am holding the
license, then all of these
are becoming
evaluation services.
They're not the
publication services.
So I could submit
to multiple of these
that have different
reputations, that
reach different
communities, that have
different interested users.
Now all of them can provide
their own evaluation,
and all of those
could be a basis
of reputation enhancement, of
what the quality of the work
is.
So there's a lot
that can be done
once there is an
open set of services
for innovation in how scholarly
communication happens.
And so really, if we think
about it as pre-print service,
it's really now a community
of article services.
It's pre-print as a term
becomes less relevant.
So we're close enough so done.
So I just want to
close with what
our hope is for a public
goods infrastructure
like this will do.
One is that it ensures that
the content and data are open.
They're always accessible,
rather than variably accessible
or not at all accessible.
Our goal is to
promote monetization
of commercial services
on providing service,
not on controlling access.
So if we can create a
core set of services,
that services ecosystem, that
any service can connect to,
but no service has control of
the entire research lifecycle,
then what the services are
doing is competing for users.
What additional things can
they provide to the researchers
to make themselves
more efficient,
to make them more effective?
And that's what should
be the basis of charging,
rather than once I get you
in to my suite of services,
then I keep you in
my suite of services.
It also promotes
interoperability.
By having a single
ecosystem, it's
in my interest as
a service provider
to make sure that my
stuff works and connects
with all of the other services.
And, as we talked about
with the pre-print example,
it can massively increase
the efficiency of creating
and maintaining those services.
Any group right now that wants
to start a pre-print service
doesn't need to think
about the technology.
They just need to think
about how their community can
interact with it.
And then obviously, by having
public goods infrastructure,
search discovery and aggregation
can improve dramatically.
And ultimately we
promote innovation
and scholarly communication.
Right now it's very
hard to innovate
in scholarly communication
because the mechanisms
of scholarly communication
are controlled
by particular organizations
that are doing very
well in the system as
it exists, and so there
isn't a lot of motivation
for innovation in the broader
scope.
But an open platform facilitates
that more dramatically.
So I will stop there so that
we have a little bit of time,
perhaps, for
questions, and you can
look at pictures of the Center
for Open Science while we talk.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
We do have a few minutes
for questions for Brian.
There are people at
the front and the back
of the room with microphones,
so if you have questions,
please look for the microphone.
There's a mic right there.
Hi.
So fantastic and
inspiring and wonderful.
Two quick questions.
So what's the response to
people, though, in terms
of getting them to
move over to an open--
to SOC archive or one
of the open pre-print
archives in terms of maintaining
their reputation scores?
So in other words,
the big challenge
is, I de-listed myself from SSRN
10 years ago because of SSRN's
controlled access policies,
the refusal, in particular,
to allow me to include a
hyperlink in an abstract.
So I am proud of having
waged that battle.
But I shot myself in the foot
professionally because I have
no download scores from SSRN.
And so I think the question
is, from an incentive
perspective for
individual users,
how do you persuade
people to move?
The second quick
question has to do
with integration with or
any relationship with Vivo,
because you're building
these enormous communities
and the question of how you
then build up, again, access
to the reputation of the people.
How do we connect into and
make more usable the knowledge
and know how with
these communities that
may come, in part, from, again,
their articles, but again,
what's back of those articles
is some fabulous people.
So I think the open source
reputation systems like Vivo
might be an interesting--
that's an interesting player.
There might be some
other play there to tap
into the expertise of people.
Great.
Thank you for those questions.
To take the second one first,
there is one Vivo integration
as those grants that we gave
for integrations to the services
ecosystem, because
I agree with you.
The kinds of data and material
available about individuals
in those kinds of
services could be
really useful to connect to the
actual content of the things
that they have
contributed, which
is the real aim with that.
But that's still in the piloting
phase or development phase.
So there's nothing
integrated yet.
On the first question
of persuading people
to use these services, or
how they use those services,
we are taking a--
as the technology
provider, which
is really what we see
as our role in this--
is a very open-ended
approach of meet researchers
where they are.
So for example, using the
open science framework.
It has open in the title, but
it doesn't require openness
at all.
Researchers can use it entirely
privately for their entire life
if they want.
They never have to make
anything accessible.
Instead, we try to solve a
problem that they have today
with those services and then
make it super easy to go open.
And then, relating closer
to the pre-prints point,
the goal is, give
researchers tools
that they can use to be
better at their research
as they do it now, and provide
access points to transition
to a more open workflow
across the entire research
lifecycle, whenever they see it
as in their interest to do so.
We don't have to persuade them.
There's other forces.
There's lots of other
forces that can persuade.
We just provide the
services to make it easy so
that they can see, ah, I can
now share this pre-print early.
I can get downloads.
And there's these
ratings out there
that provide some reputation
enhancement for me.
I see it is in my
interest to do that.
So that's really the
approach, at least,
that we have from
our organization,
but are working
with others that are
pushing on the incentives
themselves more directly.
Yes, please.
Yes, amazing.
Thank you.
It will be even more amazing
if the structures you build
persist over the centuries.
So could you talk a little
bit about how you're funded
and what the long-term
sustainability of it is?
Sustainability plans.
Yeah.
So our sustainability model is
to work really fast, figuring
that will solve it, right?
No.
So it's a key question.
So there are a couple of things.
Our funding right now is
about eight different funders,
some federal.
So we have NIH and
NSF and DRPA funding,
and then a number of private
foundations, so Laura
and John Arnold Foundation, John
Templeton Foundation, Alfred P.
Sloan Foundation, for example.
And we're continuing
to fundraise.
Our operating budget right
now is about six and 1/2
million dollars a year.
The sustainability
model-- so one key thing
for the design of these
tools is that we're
trying to make sure
that it shouldn't
matter if we continue to exist.
And so all of the stuff
is open and accessible.
We are creating '90s-style
mirroring tools so that anybody
can create a mirror of the
content that's available
as public access for the OSF.
We established, right
in our first year,
a $250,000 preservation fund.
So if we were to
disappear, that fund
would support a read-only
version of all of the data
that's hosted.
For now, given thew
amount of data we have,
that's enough for in perpetuity,
for whatever that means.
But the overall cost model,
there's funding models
that we are developing for
the transition from right now
we are moving out of
proof of concept phase
into moving to scale phase.
So we anticipate that we will
be largely foundation federally
funded for the scaling phase.
But then, if it
works, and it becomes
shared public goods
infrastructure
that we all have
a stake in, then
we can have a
distributed cost model.
So every group, based
on how much they use,
their size, their
resources, contributes some
to a community-governed
infrastructure.
So that would be the point
at which COS would not
be the governing body
of these kinds of tools,
but would hand it over to a
community of stakeholders.
And if COS continue to
exist, it would just
be like a technical partner to
help maintain those services.
Yes, please.
[INAUDIBLE] one of
your institutions?
No.
Yale doesn't have an OSF
Institutions account,
but we could do that really
fast if that's of interest.
But yeah, there's been
lots of conversations
and potential
collaborations developing
across the university here.
And I'm personally motivated,
given my academic history,
to make that happen.
[INAUDIBLE]
Good question.
So it depends on the goal.
So we have collaborations
directly with universities,
particularly for facilitating
engagement by researchers,
and then facilitating
discovery of content.
So institutional repositories
at different universities,
that's been where most of
the collaboration has been,
connecting their IRs to Share
so that metadata feat occurs.
Deeper integrations are if
there are data storage services
that the university
is providing,
that can be integrated
with the OSF.
And then when researchers
from that institution
log into their account, their
own institutional data storage
service is right there as part
of each of their projects.
So there are lots of
deep possibilities
with universities.
At the disciplinary level, it's
really more about the community
norms and incentives
for how it is
that research gets done there.
So pre-print services,
by and large,
we will likely
engage with societies
because that's really
where more of the
how do we share scholarship
and what kind of scholarship
gets shared happens.
We don't tend to pay
attention to scholarship
done at our institution
because it's
going across lots of
disciplinary boundaries
that I'm in my silo.
I'm just going to keep
thinking in my silo.
Please.
[AUDIO OUT]
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE] I mean, the point is
you don't need the university.
We'll engage with you.
I'm going to talk to you later.
Our group will engage with you.
We'll do whatever we can to
promote everything you're doing
because we believe in you.
We're not going to
wait for the university
because that just is
often too long to wait.
I think it'd be wonderful if
Steve jumps up [INAUDIBLE] we
join in a robust way.
But I don't think anybody
here should think--
your whole premise
is you don't have
to wait for the
institutions, and I
think the innovation's going to
come bottom up, not top down.
And I think if we
wait [INAUDIBLE]
policies university [INAUDIBLE]
doing the right thing,
then we'll wait a long
time for many institutions,
not our supports, which
are [INAUDIBLE] leadership
[INAUDIBLE] in this area.
I think I should step back.
[LAUGHTER]
Truly.
No, I know, Steve
--and by the way,
the physicists are the
ones who [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, for sure.
He knows [INAUDIBLE] it.
If he's got any problem,
it's that people in medicine
have got a tradition, and in
other places in the university,
of not sharing openly.
So it's actually not a will.
I mean, Steve comes
from a tradition
where [INAUDIBLE] So that
wasn't a dis on our [INAUDIBLE].
It's how you round up a faculty
that has very disparate--
and is worried about
promotion, by the way.
The practical
issues of promotion
are a thing that is a
major lever that hold back,
because you get
something in one journal,
you get something in JAMA, and
people take that as a medal,
even though we know the
reproducibility of the process
is not very good.
But you figure, on average,
stochastically, you
throw a bunch at them, they
take some, you'll get promoted.
And so we've got to
change a whole range
of different things.
But the leadership
of the universities,
I think there's a misperception
that they can just impose
[INAUDIBLE] faculty feel that.
But the truth is, they've got
to deal with an entire faculty
that's got lots of
different opinions
and [INAUDIBLE] with
regard to sharing.
So I think the best
thing we can do
to support our leadership
is to OK studies
within the university
[INAUDIBLE] you and others,
show that this is a safe
and honorable and virtuous
[INAUDIBLE].
And it gives the university
leadership some ability, then,
to then move forward.
I mean, that's the reality of
what happens in universities.
[INAUDIBLE] really
[INAUDIBLE] here
and then the whole university's
screaming and yelling
that the faculty aren't
with them [INAUDIBLE]
And there's very little
that can be imposed top
down in a university honestly.
[INAUDIBLE] have to show as a
[INAUDIBLE] not wait for Peter
to say, this is
what Yale's doing.
And then [INAUDIBLE]
there are these things
we've got to comply with.
But I can tell you it brings
people kicking and screaming.
That's why I was kidding
Karen when he said that.
But the feeling about
those are unfunded mandates
kicking and screaming
rather than waiting
the day on arguments.
And what you're saying,
let me build the tools,
let's see if people
will come, I'm
hoping that that's a better
way than imposing from NIH
this is what you must do.
Our community [INAUDIBLE]
Minimally, both need to
happen, because if you
don't have that
bottom up development,
then the top down
solutions are just
going to be
bureaucratic nightmares
from the researcher's
perspective.
[INAUDIBLE] wants to do this.
And then the leadership
can watch and see,
OK, how is this [INAUDIBLE]
And they'll be supported,
but they won't
[INAUDIBLE] are people
coalescing around these
values and issues [INAUDIBLE].
Can you speak a little
bit more about the--
in your pre-print service
or in some of the data--
about the quality
control, because more data
includes wonderful data,
and also more crap.
So whatever the virtues and
weaknesses of the peer review
system are, it is how we have
come to identify the higher
quality data.
And particularly in the
biomedical sciences,
the conduct of the study and
the collection of the data
is critical to whether we should
continue to use that data set.
So I'm not sure I understand how
your pre-print service differs
from peer review
recognized journals.
Who are those people
doing those reviews,
and how do we peer
review those reviewers?
So good questions.
The quality control
is essentially
the core function, a filtering
mechanism of the peer review
process.
What's worth reading?
And whatever its flaws,
that has some value.
So the pre-print services,
the communities themselves
that launch their
pre-print services
decide on their own
quality control standards.
So Archive, for
example, has a standard
of, is it science and
does a reviewer that
has some expertise in that
discipline read it and say,
yep, that's
scholarship that fits
the broad parameters of what
we are willing to share.
And it has been very effective.
That's a longstanding--
it's 400,000 submissions,
or no, it's less than that.
But there's, like, 1.2 million
pre-prints on archive now.
And that's been very effective.
Bio Archive has its
own set of standards
for what it is that
it will include
in its pre-print service.
So our goal is to facilitate
the creation of many services.
You'll say, oh, Bio
Archives isn't really good
enough for what I want to do.
I'm going start
my own, and we'll
have a different
set of criteria.
And then let the
marketplace decide
whether yours is more worth
looking at than Bio Archive's
is worth looking at.
For us it doesn't matter.
We just want to
facilitate the creation
of different ways of doing that
evaluation, that filtering.
And just like how
we absorb our news,
the services will
provide information
about what's worth
paying attention to.
If it's in Huffington Post
versus in New York Times,
I might have
different assumptions
about whether that
information is worth reading,
and the same will be true
of these kinds of services.
So we won't impose it from
the technical provider.
Yeah, please.
First of all, I
just want to say,
in principle, I applaud
what you're doing
and I think it is overall
a wonderful thing.
But I was wondering if you've--
and this is more of an
existential question.
And as an example--
Should I lie down?
In the aftermath
of the election,
one of the lobbying
groups that's
gotten a lot of attention
is a conservative group
that seeks to cut government
funding for what they consider
to be wasteful research.
And they're seeking to align
with animal rights groups
to say-- right now their target
is to cut dog research done
by the NIH.
And they've made very clear
they want to eventually just cut
funding for all animal
research across the board,
for any government funded.
I know that at Yale, the
university cautions us
about putting any animal
experiment images that
might be accessible
to the public
because that could be used
against the university.
You know, lab members
could get stalked, right?
And I was wondering,
there's a possibility
that your tool may actually
stifle the very innovation
that you seek to propagate.
And I understand it's
not an easy question
and there's not answer
on that, but I just
want to get your
thoughts on that.
Yeah.
No, that is a very
important one,
is that any move to
a cultural change
will have unintended
consequences that
are hard to anticipate.
And so incremental
revolutions are
good because they allow
corrections along the way.
You do one step.
You see what happens.
You make corrections.
You do another step.
And so that, I think,
is really where
this whole reproducibility
and openness
movement is going if it
goes effectively, is really
trying and testing,
and then making sure
that the kinds of
risk situations
are addressed effectively,
like what gets shared.
I have a colleague that
does research on abortion
and the psychological
effects of abortion.
And of course the same
sorts of concerns come up.
How can I possibly share
some of this stuff?
This is very-- it is so
politicized that there's
lots of risks for doing that.
And so we have to have--
no single imposed solution is
going to be the right solution.
There'll be lots of occasions
which we say, some of this
needs to remain closed.
And it doesn't necessarily
mean entirely closed.
It may mean closed with
permission to access.
And so who is it that gets
access to that kind of content
or that kind of work?
And so all systems
need to be very--
any open system,
its top priority
has to be security because
some stuff can't be opened.
And when you have an
integrated system that
has some stuff open
and some stuff not,
security is priority one because
of exactly the kinds of issues
that you raise.
Thanks.
About practicality
and encryption,
I saw you have some
website pages that
probably are the platform.
Are you using a
security protocol?
Do you have any
encryption between APIs
especially for data
storage and product
management, because when
you describe your project,
you're a bit aware of
your competition as well,
and you'd rather have
that good encrypted.
Yes.
So there are a variety
of encryption standards.
We don't encrypt
the stored data now.
There are hosting
solutions-- there
are other hosting
solutions that do that.
There are some
pluses and minuses
of encrypting the
data as the data.
But that's going
into some weeds.
So there are
encryption standards.
And there are also things that
are privacy standards that one
can do eventual openness.
So I didn't mention in
the registry service,
if I want to register
my designs in advance,
have a clear
confirmatory design,
but I'm worried
about competition
from other people in the field,
I can embargo my registration.
So I register.
It will become available
sometime in the next four
years, whatever date
I select, but it
can stay private until that
time so that I can still
show I did register
this in advance,
but still have the
value of a registry that
makes it available over time.
So it's really trying to be
sensitive to the community
as it exists now and make
it super easy to transition
in different ways, depending
on how the issues of openness
evolve.
Thank you very
much for the time.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]